The rise of mobile platforms
revolutionized gaming
in more ways than one.
Not only did it put a powerful
game device in everyone's pocket,
it also introduced two major
technological improvements to the way we
interact with computers and games.
Touch and orientation detection.
Touch, including multi touch and
gestures, can make game controls
feel natural and totally seamless.
They allow you to provide a direct
physical connection to your game.
If it's done right, it can make all
the difference to the feel in gameplay.
Games like Angry Birds and Fruit Ninja
showed everyone what can be accomplished
with this funky new input method.
And there's really no question that
touch made those games successful.
It's hard to imagine
either game without it.
Accelerometers allow for a second new
form of input, orientation detection.
Knowing how the phone or tablet is
positioned or moving through space,
opens up all kinds of opportunities
to make your game more immersive.
Whether it's a driving
game you have to steer, or
an augmented reality app, the
accelerometer gives you control options
that have really never
been available on PC.